the Las Vegas Book Festival is back this
year for its 21st year there'll be
something for everyone headlining
authors book signings Book Sales and so
much more even food trucks we're live
this morning from the historic Fifth
Street School where the Book Festival is
happening with Dr Lisa Morris hibler
with the city of Las Vegas good morning
Dr Hitler I want you to tell us all
about the book festival and who really
is this event for
well good morning Sherry we are so
excited to be back you know during the
pandemic we sort of had a virtual and a
hybrid Book Festival so we're glad that
people can come out this Saturday to the
Las Vegas
historic history school and it is for
everyone it is for all ages we have
everything for kids activities all the
way to our active seniors and we're
really glad to be able to bring the
headliners that we have this year
so uh what can we expect you've got uh
discussions you've got authors signing
books you've even got kids activities
and so uh what what can everyone look
forward to
so first of all we're excited about our
three Headliners we have Carl Bernstein
who's most famously known for helping to
break Watergate we have Ellen Hildebrand
who writes a series of books set in
Nantucket Massachusetts so she's going
to be here for hotel in Nantucket and
then we have a young artist that's
author that's on the scene and her name
is Kylie Reed and she wrote a book on
such a fun age and so you know we have a
lot of different genres we have
panelists poets there's just something
for everyone oh it sounds fun and it
it's free right you don't have to pay to
get in what about parking where can
people go how can they get there and and
find the place the festival and what are
the hours
yeah it's absolutely free it's from ten
to seven we'll have food vendors uh
we'll have a lot of different booths set
up we try to make parking easy so you
can go to our parking City Hall parking
garage at 495 Main Street and take the
downtown Loop we'll transport you over
to the Book Festival
and so um there's you know I know
there's a lot of activities always in
Vegas but we're hoping everybody comes
out and joins us for the Las Vegas Book
Festival all right it's really important
I mean we have so many Avid readers we
have so many book clubs here in Las
Vegas and it's really an important
Festival especially if you love reading
and especially bring the kids to so
thank you so much Dr hibler we
appreciate you being here and and I'm so
glad that you're going to have it I'm
going to try and work on the wind for
you because I know you're going to be
outdoors a lot thank you I'll try as
much as I can have a great Festival I
would look forward to seeing everyone
down there
and thanks Sherry you betcha great to
see you